every time I talk to you I ask you the
same question today is going to be no
different
what do I need to do to get a national
treasure for it well that's a Disney
question not me we're certainly working
on one for streaming and we're also
working on one for the big screen
so hopefully they'll both come together
and we'll bring another national
treasure but they're both very active do
you think there's more of a chance of it
happening now with Disney plus I mean is
there a chance that it could be made for
that format or you guys envisioning it
as the actual that would eventually go
to Disney once well we're one for Disney
Plus is is a much younger cast so it's
it's a different it's the same concept
but a young cast and one through
theatrical would be with it with the
same cast can I ask how far along you
are on version well the the film version
is being written right now and the
television version is in process we have
I think a pilot script done and we have
the the episodes an outline of the
future episodes